when you built this os this multi-touch
gestural os for fingers
you didn't do it in a tablet right away
did it in the phone what was the
i mean did you consider doing a tablet
when you did the iphone or
or was it just a natural progression the
iphone came out it was a big hit i'll
actually tell you kind of a secret okay
okay
i actually started on the tablet first
and uh
i
had this idea of being able to
get rid of the keyboard
type on a multi-touch glass display
and i asked our folks could we come up
with a multi-touch
display
that i would type on i could rest my
hands on and actually type on
and about six months later they called
me in and showed me this prototype
display
and it was amazing
and i gave it to one of our guys
this was in the early 90s i mean early
early 2000s
and i gave it to one of our other really
brilliant
ui folks
and he called me back a few weeks later
and he had inertial scrolling working
and a few other things now we were
thinking about building a phone at that
time
and when i saw the rubber band inertial
scrolling and a few of the other things
i thought my god
we can build a phone out of this
and i put the tablet project on the
shelf
because the phone was more important
and we went took the next several years
and did the iphone
7
and when we got our when we got our
wind back
and uh thought we could take on
something next
pull the tablet off the shelf took
everything we learned from the phone
went back to work on a tablet if you
want to see how steve jobs started apple
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there
we had absolutely no idea what people
were going to do these things when we
started out uh matter of fact the two
people it was designed for was woz and
myself
because we couldn't afford to buy a
computer kit on the market